what is illegal offline should be
illegal online the basis of landmark
digital services rules now signed off by
parliament tech platforms that fail to
comply with strict fairness and safety
standards risk being fined up to six
percent of their global turnover
more than 20 million tons of grain are
blocked in ukraine in the wake of
russia's invasion parliament demanded eu
action to ease agricultural exports from
the country and prevent a global food
crisis
as many as 50 million people in the eu
workers in formal carers most of them
women
parliament urge recognition of a right
to care it wants legal and financial
measures to ensure decent working
conditions and make the sector more
attractive
meps reaffirmed their support for safe
access to abortion condemning
backsliding on women's rights in the
united states and elsewhere
it comes after the u.s supreme court
overturned 1973's roe v wade ruling
croatia is well on the way to becoming
the eurozone's 20th member meps backed
its bid to join the single currency on
january the 1st 2023 the final decision
lies with the 19 member states
[Music]